[Music]
chuck we spent a whole explainer talking
about constellations and i didn't finish
oh cool can you let me continue it
excellent yes with your permission
[Laughter]
granted sir let's see if you learned
anything from the first session how many
constellations are there oh god 48.
did i get it
no
chuck
i said
what there are as many constellations as
there are keys on a piano oh that's
right 88 i got half of it right
it's not gonna work
i got the eight right
[Laughter]
if we're going to the moon and the
engineer says i got half of it right
well you got there i mean you're not
going out in space missing your target
you're not coming back i got half of it
right
all right so we said some cool things i
think 88
of southern hemisphere constellations
known to indigenous people from the
southern hemisphere right would be later
discovered by
europeans and when they named it they
had they were already deep into the
industrial revolution so they started
naming them not after mythical magical
creatures but after like stuff
that was enabling the emergence of a new
kind of brand a new like sexton another
level of civilization there's a sextant
by the way before the sextant was
invented which was
60 degrees of a circle
okay
there's six of those six times 60 is 360
degrees what preceded that was an octant
wow okay that was an eighth of 360
degrees the sky has a sexting and an
octet in it very nice
that feels a little excessive to me all
right
you know be happy with one but no you
want two two out of the 88
constellations are navigational devices
that are kind of the same you know you
never have too many tools
i don't know if that's true okay never
can't open anything so a couple of
things um
what's in your mind the most famous
constellation in the southern hemisphere
oh in the southern
god see so what i was going to say but
that's not southern was big dipper but
everybody knows that yeah that's the
north yeah that's the new york okay yeah
you're southern 8 000 miles off i know
um
i said it wasn't that nice no 9 out of
10 people say the southern cross i was
about to say the cross you didn't you
would not
i really was
no let me tell you something i really
was about to say the cross but i was
scared to do so because one night we
were sitting out and you had your
you know top secret uh sky pointer
government issue
and you were and you but there's a cross
in the north too yeah that you would and
so that's why i would i was about to say
across but okay so there's a northern
cross which we love here in the northern
hemisphere and there's a southern cross
but they're really different from each
other
okay the southern cross is
embarrassing compared to the northern
cross oh no okay the southern cross
has
four stars in it
okay it's in the shape of a rhombus
there is no star there's no at the
transept right yeah so you could have
just drawn a rhombus
to remind people from eighth grade
geometry a rhombus is like take a
perfect square sit on it
distort the sides and then you get a
rhombus okay
so it is a stretch
to call the southern cross across
it's a stretch i'm just telling you wow
not only that of all 88 constellations
the southern cross is the smallest
oh
your thumbnail at arm's reach
would completely cover all four stars of
the southern cross oh
it is one of the biggest
marketing delusions there ever was and
isn't there crosby stills
uh song crosby net um
yeah i was gonna say csr that's uh you
know it's a little caucasian for me i'm
just
saying i mean don't get me wrong but you
know so this i just want to put put it
out there with the southern cross now
have you ever met people who have
visited the southern hemisphere anywhere
be it africa or australia right and and
they come back and what do they tell you
about the sky
uh i you know i never really got into it
i normally ask them about the place they
were see that's that's the clubs how's
that exactly you know tell me about the
food what did you see you know only you
would be like and so the night sky yeah
i'm sorry i'm telling you more about
that nice god
what happens is people visit the
southern hemisphere and they come back
and say the southern hemisphere
atmosphere sky is so beautiful
it is so amazing
oh my gosh
and
and so there's another little delusion
going on there as well
and what is that i don't want to stop
you from liking the southern hemisphere
sky better than the north
uh
i have no problems with that
but there are forces operating that
contaminate your data
okay okay do you know how much of
earth's land is in the southern
hemisphere
um i would say not a lot not a lot about
i mean when you look at africa it's like
that's most of it yes okay about 15
of earth's land mass is south of the
equator
okay that's also about 15 percent of
earth's population
okay
so hardly anybody lives in the southern
hemisphere right
so there's hardly any city lights
hardly any light pollution air pollution
all the things that subtract away from
our experience embracing the sky in the
north does not
block your view in the south so people
think the actual sky is better
because they can see it better
wow
so
i'm telling you
that the north has all the coolest
constellations
all right you know with the big dipper
and you know and the little dipper and
the you know and
and and cassiopeia some constellations
straddle the north and the south or ryan
is half in the north and half in the
south but when we look at him he's right
side up you want to see orion in the
southern hemisphere he's upside down
that there's
there's no excuse for that
so i'm just i'm a northern chauvinist
here but i think i have good reason for
it
yeah but the the problem is we can't see
it
i mean you can be as hot as you want
you know but if you're walking around in
a burlap sack nobody's gonna know nobody
knows how hot you are
wow so yeah so this is an interesting
fact about it
now here's a so the northern cross is
much bigger than the southern cross and
there's a star in the transept for it
okay it's called and that's an asterism
an asterism is a set of stars
that is the more interesting subset of
all the stars that comprise the
constellation
so
the northern cross is cygnus the swan
the constellation which is not only
those stars in the cross but there are
other stars where you can imagine wings
and it's flying long neck
neck swan along the milky way so it's a
beautiful
thought that there's a swan doing this
but it's bluntly across
now
last thing i'll tell you there's more
but i just want to sort of put it out
there
um
many of the star star constellations are
all greek and some late latter day
technologically related ones but some of
the earliest navigators were the arabs
okay the entire arabian peninsula all
those folks there are very few clouds
because it's desert and so you saw the
night sky and you want to get around
there's no monuments there's no gps
there are no mile markers how are you
going to get around
so they pioneered astrolabes which was
their version of the european sextant
okay and the octet the astrolabe they
did it first and and it's beautiful
works of art with rotating dials and you
hold it up and you can get the angle and
their tables and charts it's
magnificent all etched in brass
beautiful we have a collection at the
american museum of natural history but
one of the largest collections in the
world is at the adler planetarium and
astronomy museum in chicago
they have one of the largest collections
of astrolabes in the world anyhow point
is
as an homage
to
the arabic role in navigating the sky
two-thirds of all stars in the sky that
have names
have arabic names oh wow
this is part of the sort of
inclusiveness of my field
where if you contributed to it we're not
going to forget you and and by the way
in the constellation libra
the scales
um the two brightest stars in that
constellation are arabic
names one of them is zubin el janubi and
the other is zubin s shamali
okay those are the two longest star
names of all name stars in the sky and
what is the abbreviation for
pound
lbs lb you know what lb stands for uh
uh
no i don't
libra
the scales it just gets worse
first you go from pounds to lb right
right
and lb is just short for libra this is
libra right the measurement of things
that's so cool all right that's been a
an explainer consolation part two
and i'm gonna stop there i could go on
but we gotta we can't
we can't let other stuff go unexplained
while we spend all this time on consoles
well we'll come back to it so
next time we come back we will leap to
another place that's in desperate need
of explaining awesome
chuck always good to have you always a
pleasure all right neil degrasse tyson
here your personal astrophysicist keep
looking up
[Music]
you